[Aplausos]
[Música]
desde que estalló la guerra en Ucrania
los analistas se han vuelto
completamente locos intentando prever
Qué puede pasar una vez que se termine
el conflicto si es que eso ocurre algún
día y ojo porque hay quienes incluso han
proyectado que podría estar en juego la
mismísima desintegración de Rusia como
país unificado vale puede que muchas de
estas teorías sean pura propaganda
estimaciones al límite o dadas las
circunstancias atiendan a ciertos
intereses pero no dejan de ser curiosas
y desde luego lo que aquí en
visualpolitik más nos importa es que
muchos de sus argumentos son ciertos
Pues bien una de estas teorías nos ha
llamado mucho la atención porque se
pregunta algo que la mayoría quizás no
nos habríamos planteado jamás Hasta qué
punto puede contribuir el yihadismo a la
desintegración de Rusia
que justo ahora os estaréis preguntando
a ver Alberto qué demonios tiene que ver
el yihadismo con Rusia hay acaso tantos
musulmanes en la federación Pues sí Lo
cierto es que sí aproximadamente el 15%
de toda la población rusa es musulmana y
se prevé que esta cifra pueda superar el
20% para el año 2030
y llamándome loco pero Hablamos de una
población musulmana que en pocos años
superará ampliamente los 25 millones de
habitantes lo que viene a ser el doble
de la población que tiene Moscú Así que
diría que este sí que es un tema
relevante no os parece y no sólo eso es
que además el islam es la religión
mayoritaria en varias regiones de Rusia
fijaos en este mapa como podéis ver son
siete los territorios con mayoría
musulmana en Rusia las cinco repúblicas
autónomas del cáucaso Norte así como
tartaristán y más cortostán en la región
del volga ural Y aunque en Rusia como
tal no hay una religión oficial
supuestamente se constituye como un
estado laico a la hora de la verdad la
religión atraviesa todo el campo de la
política nacional y si no que se lo
digan al patriarca kiril el líder de la
iglesia ortodoxa Dice que los soldados
rusos que mueran en Ucrania quedarán
limpios de pecado
en cualquier caso lo cierto Es que la
mayor parte del país el ortodoxo es la
región mayoritaria cerca del 80% de los
rusos se declaran como tal Aunque lo
cierto es que son muy poco practicantes
algunos datos apuntan a que apenas el 4%
asisten regularmente a oficios
religiosos claro que el peso de la
iglesia ortodoxa ha crecido en los
últimos años Gracias precisamente a
Putin
estamos simplemente al comienzo del
renacimiento espiritual de nuestro
pueblo patriarca kiril sea como sea pese
a ello en los siete territorios donde el
islam es mayoritario incluso las haría
está la orden del día especialmente en
la repúblicas del cáucaso Norte queréis
un ejemplo Pues digamos que más vale que
en chechenia no te vean demasiado
cariñosos o cariñosa con alguien de tu
mismo sexo porque o te pegan una paliza
hasta matarte o te mandan directamente a
un campo de concentración Sí así se las
gastan en esta zona del mundo en este
territorio muchas mezquitas han dedicado
a radicalizar a todos los feligreses que
podían para alimentar el yihadismo en
chechenia el
y en general en todas las regiones
musulmanas de Rusia por tanto Sabiendo
todo esto La pregunta es hasta qué punto
por el yihadismo convertirse en un
verdadero problema para Moscú Cómo ha
sido hasta ahora el movimiento de estos
grupos en Rusia Hasta qué punto hablamos
de un choque inminente que puede
alimentar incluso deseos secesionistas
en este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el emirato del cáucaso
Estoy seguro que más o menos todos
sabemos la historia del estado islámico
durante años los medios no pararon de
bombardearnos con noticias de sus
avances en Siria y en Irak pero seguro
seguro que serías muy pocos Pues que
sepáis que Rusia tuvo que hacer frente
en su propio territorio a un movimiento
yihadista parecido al del estado
islámico Sí sí habéis escuchado bien
hablamos del emirato del cáucaso vale Es
verdad que no fue tan grande ni tuvo
tanto impacto en Rusia como el estadio
islámico en Oriente medio pero aún así
resultó un auténtico quebradero de
cabeza para Putin pensad que si el
emirato se hubiera convertido en un
estado hubiera sido más grande en
territorio y población que Georgia
Armenia y azerbaiyán pero claro La
pregunta es tan importante es el islam
en Rusia como para que unos cuantos
radicales llegaron a crear su propio
emirato Pues digamos que sí Y desde
luego es más importante de lo que
podríais llegar a pensar
el islam llegó al territorio del actual
Rusia en el siglo 7 extendiéndose
justamente por el cáucaso desde entonces
ya fueran dar
chechenia el Isla comenzó a fuerza
hasta convertirse en la región
mayoritaria de toda la región caucásica
Claro que no fue un proceso limpio sino
que estuvo acompañado de varias campañas
de represión contra la población
musulmana de la región y también contra
los tártaros musulmanes del volcán desde
Iván el Terrible en el siglo XVI hasta
la unión soviética el islam estuvo
duramente reprimido por largos periodos
de tiempo en lo que hoy comprende la
madre Rusia sin embargo con la caída de
la unión soviética volvió la apertura
religiosa y con ello el resurgir de la
fe musulmana en el país y no solo eso
también comenzaron a crearse
instituciones musulmanas como la unión
de musulmanes de Rusia y numerosas
magrasas y universidades islámicas Como
por ejemplo la universidad islámica de
dagestán de hecho el islam es tan
importante que incluso fue reconocido en
la legislación nacional como una de las
cuatro religiones tradicionales del país
y como decíamos es la felicidad por el
10% de toda la población de Rusia es
decir unos 15 millones de personas Claro
que hablamos de una población
relativamente más joven y con más hijos
motivos por el cual su peso no deja de
crecer
y vale Es cierto que el hecho de que
haya una población musulmana
razonablemente grande en un país no
significa que tengan que existir Sí o sí
problemas con facciones radicales pero
queridos amigos amigas puede no ocurrir
pero este sí ha sido el caso de Rusia
[Música]
de hecho el emirato del cáucaso no es
más que la herencia de los
enfrentamientos y las dos guerras
sangrientas entre Rusia y chechenia que
se libraron entre principios de los 90 y
bien entrado el siglo XXI Y es que como
seguramente muchos sepáis la tensión
entre Rusia y chenia ha sido
tradicionalmente muy alta Ya en la Rusia
zarista los chechenos se levantaron en
armas contra los rusos para intentar
conseguir su independencia y durante la
época soviética chechenia fue unida a
industria para formar una sola República
de hecho se llevaban tan mal con Rusia
que lucharon junto a los nazis y al
final cuando La Unión soviética se auto
declaró independiente en 1991 pero no
fue hasta 1994 cuando
Moscú reaccionó con toda su fuerza y
desde Entonces hasta 2002 las
operaciones militares se mantuvieron en
chechenia poniendo oficialmente final
conflicto Aunque luego la insurgencia se
extendió todavía unos cuantos años más
sea como sea esto supuso todo un
espaldarazo para el entonces nuevo líder
ruso digamos que con las tropas ya
apostadas en chechenia mostrando su
poderío Putin empezó a respirar con
tranquilidad los ataques terroristas de
los separatistas chechenos comenzaron a
dejar de producirse bajo la atenta
mirada del padre de nuestro viejo
conocido ramsam kadir pero lo que no
sabía Putin era que aunque cerró la
puerta del separatismo checheno
automáticamente se abrió una amplia
ventana al terrorismo yihadista Y esa
ventana dio lugar a que en 2007 el líder
separatista cheno gokumaru creara el
emirato del cáucaso y comenzara contra
Rusia Pero qué fue exactamente Esto del
emirato del cáucaso
pues es básicamente el proyecto de un
nuevo estado independiente Regido por la
sharía y que ocuparía todo el caucaso
norte es decir No solo la repúblicas
autónomas de la región como chechenia
sino todo el territorio que va desde la
gestán hasta el propio mar de azzo y
Seguro seguro que muchos estáis pensando
que chechenia era la parte más
importante de este nuevo emirato verdad
pues error la gestán se llevó la palma
los yihadistas de chechenia no se
contentaron con quedarse en la tierra de
kadiro sino que empezaron a expandirse
por la región de hecho para que os
hagáis una idea el Emir que sucedió a
humanos fue un dagestano luego otra
prueba de que David Stan se terminó
convirtiendo en el epicentro del
yihadismo en la región es que esta fue
precisamente la región con más Víctimas
de heridos por atentados terroristas de
corte yihadista chechenia oppo por tanto
un segundo escalón pero Quiénes son
estos grupos que impulsaron el emirato
del cáucaso qué peso real tienen en la
región que peligro suponen son todos los
musulmanes partidarios de esta línea de
acción contra Moscú Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
sufismo versus salafismo
de verdad que en visualpolitik sabemos
perfectamente que eso de explicar las
diferencias entre distintas ramas dentro
de una misma religión no es una tarea
nada fácil y por supuesto el islam no es
ninguna excepción por eso para
comprender el problema del yihadismo hay
que conocer las principales diferencias
vamos a hacerlo sencillo Ya lo hemos
visto en alguna que otra ocasión el
islam está dividido fundamentalmente en
dos grandes familias los unitas y los
chitas Esta división se remonta a poco
después de la muerte de Mahoma en el 632
después de Cristo desde entonces los
musulmanes quedaron divididos por un
lado estaban los que creían que los
Califas debían ser los Sucesores del
profeta Empezando por el primo yerno de
Mahoma Ali Y estos eran y son los
chiitas que por su carácter hereditario
mantienen una jerarquía liderada por los
ayatolas mucho más centralizada
influyente y luego por otro lado están
los musulmanes que no creían que Mahoma
hubiera dejado Herederos religiosos
directos y que por tanto Los líderes
espirituales tenía ser Escogidos por la
propia comunidad estos fueron los
sunitas cuya organización se basa en una
enorme descentralización Pues bien como
en casi todo el mundo en Rusia dos
unitas también son mayoría pero ojo
porque dentro del sunismo también hay
otras divisiones y la que más nos
interesa es la que existe en el cáucaso
norte entre sufistas y salafistas y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando a ver si son
de la misma rama musulmana no tendrá
muchas diferencias No pues nada más
lejos de la realidad
[Música]
podríamos decir que en general el
sufismo Es una rama minoritaria en el
mundo musulmán su énfasis A diferencia
de la mayoría sunita no está en La
pureza de los ritos religiosos sino
sobre todo en la vida espiritual es
decir buscan una relación más Mística
con ala desde un plano muy individual
respetando Eso sí siempre los Pilares
básicos del islam es el Abismo Por otra
parte es mucho muchísimo más
fundamentalista
el salafismo tradicionalista además de
La pureza de la doctrina se concentrará
en la predicación con vistas a reforzar
la fe preservar la cohesión de la
comunidad y defender el orden moral
islámico un discurso que coincide con la
ruptura con los musulmanes más tibios
Federico aznar Fernández Montesinos
Y es que no se diferencian únicamente en
cuanto a su visión más o menos
individualista o colectivista por
ejemplo los salafistas rechazan la
innovación en el islam porque la
consideran una desviación del camino
marcado por ala su objetivo es restaurar
la práctica original del islam
rechazando la influencia de la cultura y
las tradiciones locales lo sufíes en
cambio toleran y promueven cierta
Innovación incluso tienen sus propios
Santos algo que los salafistas rechazan
completamente Pero quizás la diferencia
más importante sigue siendo su postura
frente a la yihad ya que los salafistas
la defienden en gran medida mientras que
los fieles son mucho pero que mucho más
moderados
como podéis ver no podemos decir ni
mucho menos que el sufismo y el
salafismo sean gemelos por eso no
resulta que allí donde se encuentran
ambos a la vez suele aparecer la tensión
y el conflicto entre ambas facciones que
es precisamente el caso del cáucaso
Norte
[Música]
aquí el sufismo está bien establecido y
es la rama del islam que lógicamente
tiene el apoyo de Moscú sin embargo pese
a ello la realidad es que el salafismo
ha cogido fuerza desde Las Guerras en
chechenia y según algunas estimaciones
hasta 700.000 musulmanes podrían haberlo
adoptado en Rusia o sea como sea el
salafismo actual comenzó su expansión a
nivel Global en los años 70 Gracias en
gran medida al dinero de Arabia saudí
que se dedicó a construir mezquitas a
las fiestas por todo el mundo y claro
como era de esperar muchas de estas
mezquitas no solo se hacían meros
oficios inocentes sino que en sí mismo
también servían como centros de
radicalización y desde luego como todos
podemos imaginarnos cuanto peor están
las circunstancias en un lugar más fácil
resulta radicalizar la fe por eso el
salafismo ha sido tan Popular en el
cáucaso norte porque su repúblicas
autónomas tienen los peores datos
económicos de Rusia Para que saques una
idea tiene el desempleo más alto con un
30%, la pobreza en carachay charquesis
alcanza el 25%. y de hecho echad un
vistazo a esta tabla
[Música]
como podéis ver las cinco repúblicas
autónomas del cáucaso ruso se encuentran
entre las 10 regiones más pobres del
país Claro que esta lucha entre sufismo
y salafismo no es exclusiva en el
cáucaso encontramos algo muy parecido en
África por ejemplo en ghana entre el año
2000 y 2010 las ongs a las fiestas del
país construyeron 91 mezquitas y 89
colegios y en todo el continente
africano la agencia Cuba Haití de
musulmanes de África ha llegado a cifrar
en 6000 las mezquitas y 800 los centros
educativos que los salafistas han
construido en los últimos 35 años por lo
tanto Hablamos de una lucha entre el
sufismo y el salafismo de carácter
Global en este caso en Rusia
Moscú se alineó con el sufismo para
pararle los pies al salafismo yihadista
y a decir verdad han tenido bastante
éxito al menos hasta ahora atentos
[Música]
el antídoto ruso al salafismo
como ya hemos visto tras la caída de la
unión soviética la religión volvió a
formar parte de nuevo de la sociedad
rusa Claro que no todas las religiones
han sido tratadas por igual de hecho el
cristianismo ortodoxo se ha beneficiado
y mucho de esta nueva tolerancia con la
religión mientras el resto de Europa iba
separando cada vez más las relaciones
entre el estado y la religión Rusia ha
financiado generosamente a la iglesia
ortodoxa le ha dado privilegios de todo
tipo le ha permitido enseñar su religión
en los Colegios influir decisivamente en
las leyes y por supuesto construir todas
las iglesias que quieran lo que supone
un claro punto de tensión con la
comunidad musulmana del país fijaos
no encuentran sitio en la mezquita por
ejemplo mientras en Moscú hay 600
Iglesias ortodoxas públicas apenas hay
un puñado de mezquitas públicas de libre
acceso para entre 2 y 4 millones de
musulmanes que se calcula que hay en
Moscú lógicamente con todos estos
privilegios el caldo cultivo para el
radicalismo está más que servido pero
Putin lo sabe Y por eso también ha
procurado mantener buenas relaciones con
los musulmanes rusos digamos que apoyar
al islam institucionalizado sobre todo
al de corte sufrí en el cáucaso es la
forma con la que quiere luchar contra el
salafismo yihadista
[Música]
desde Moscú se apoya el islam vinculado
a tres instituciones el consejo ruso de
los muffitis la junta central de
clérigos musulmanes y el centro de
coordinación de los musulmanes del
cáucaso Norte si las organizaciones
musulmanas del país y de las repúblicas
autónomas del cáucaso quieren recibir
financiación pública de estas
instituciones ser salafistas no les
servirá absolutamente De nada además
Moscú también se ha centrado en extender
la educación del Isla tanto en escuelas
como en centros de reeducación de
excombatientes yihadistas lo cual es
especialmente importante por el
atractivo que el salafismo tiene las
generaciones más jóvenes
sin embargo lo que más Mella ha
conseguido hacer en el salafismo del
cáucaso ha sido la acción directa es
decir la acción militar
después de aprobar una serie de leyes a
finales de los 90 y principios del nuevo
siglo sobre las asociaciones religiosas
y la lucha contra las actividades
terroristas
Moscú se puso manos a la obra tanto con
sus efectivos militares que al menos
hasta el comienzo de la guerra en
Ucrania se cifraban en unos 80.000
soldados desplegados en la región como
con los ejércitos de los hombres fuertes
de Putin como es por ejemplo el caso del
propio cadirov de esta forma el
yihadismo ha ido perdiendo fuerza de
hecho la presión y los acuerdos de Moscú
con muchos jennifaltes locales hicieron
que la propia población del cáucaso
estuviera comprometida en la lucha
contra el yihadismo y si no me creéis
preguntarle a estas mujeres de chenas
engañando al mal mujeres chinas engaño
análisis haciéndose pasar por novias de
terroristas vale No es la acción más
heroica del mundo pero aquí lo que
cuenta es quitarle dinero a los
yihadistas Así que Chapó por ellas y a
decir verdad Es la falta de dinero lo
que también ha hecho que haya perdido
fuelle el yihadismo ruso desde la
aparición del estado técnico en Siria e
Irak la mayor parte del dinero de la
yihad global fue a parar allí y el
emirato del cáucaso se quedó tanto sin
dinero como sin combatientes Así que
estando así las cosas al final eliminato
del cáucaso el mayor exponente de las
aspiraciones salafistas yihadistas en
Rusia desapareció en 2016
[Música]
Pero cuidado porque esto no significa
que el salafismo como tal haya
desaparecido es más sigue siendo
tremendamente popular entre la juventud
caucásica porque les ofrece una salida
en un territorio donde las oportunidades
verían por su ausencia y no solamente
para los caucásicos en tartaristan otra
República Autónoma dentro de Rusia en la
zona del volga oral también hubo grupos
yihadistas algunos de ellos han
protagonizado noticias como esta líderes
musulmanes rusos atacados en tartaristán
en general hasta ahora Rusia ha sabido
contener la oleada De terrorismo
yihadista que asoló al país y al cáucaso
norte y en años anteriores ese proyecto
separatista yihadista que fue eliminato
del cáucaso fracasó ante la mano dura de
Putin y sus hombres fieles por eso puede
que las teorías que han surgido a raíz
de la guerra en Ucrania sobre las
presiones secesionistas de la Rusia
islámica pueden ser exageradas sin
embargo esperando un momento
si las cosas en Rusia se siguen poniendo
peor con las sanciones impactando en la
economía y un flujo constante de jóvenes
muriendo en el frente eso podría
convertirse en el punto de inflexión
perfecto para que volviera no solo a
cobrar fuerzas al salacismo sino también
los deseos secesionistas de la Rusia
musulmana y ojo porque la historia nos
dice que no resulta tan fácil mantener
territorios ampliamente islámicos bajo
el control de un estado que cada vez
está más ligado a otra religión en este
caso el cristianismo ortodoxo Así que
este es queridos amigos amigas uno de
los puntos débiles a los que Rusia
Podría tener que enfrentarse Durante los
próximos años o incluso décadas una
población pobre y joven de más de 25
millones de musulmanes con una identidad
cultural y religiosa tan diferente a la
de Moscú podría terminar convirtiéndose
en toda una bomba de relojería pero
dicho esto Ahora la pregunta es para
todos vosotros
si la estrategia de Rusia para frenar el
yihadismo y el salafismo puede
replicarse en todo el mundo es el
yihadismo en Rusia un Gigante Dormido
que puede despertar en cualquier momento
y desatar el caos en la madre Rusia
podría llegar a provocar el surgimiento
de movimiento separatistas en un futuro
próximo puedes dejarnos vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante No olvides darle
al botón de like y como siempre nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto